in the nation most devastated by the
global pandemic
the first doses of the first approved
vaccine are on the move
within the next 24 hours they will begin
moving vaccine from the pfizer
manufacturing facility
to the ups and fedex hubs and then it
will go out to the 636
locations nationwide the first
145 sites in the u.s are expected to
receive the vaccine on monday with the
rest receiving it by wednesday
now front line responders like dr ben
yousach in colorado
will be among the first to be vaccinated
against covid19
i am going to be one of the tips of the
spear one of the first people
to step in to help generate this herd
immunity
which is so important to us to get a
grip on this terrible disease
those first vaccinations will happen
just days after the u.s food and drug
administration approved it on friday
science and data guided the fda's
decision
we worked quickly based on the urgency
of this pandemic
not because of any other external
pressure that external pressure came
from president
trump who on friday tweeted to han to
quote get the damn vaccines out now
trump on saturday called it a victory
our nation has achieved a medical
miracle we have delivered a safe and
effective vaccine in just
nine months the vaccine has shown to be
95 percent effective in preventing covet
19 transmission
but it must be stored at ultra cold
temperatures
the road to immunity across the u.s is
likely to be paved with
pain and tragedy the head of the u.s
centers for disease control says over
the next 60 to 90 days
some 3 000 americans that's more than
were killed in the 9 11 attacks
will die each day of covert 19.
then there are the conspiracy theorists
and skeptics who say they will refuse to
take it
i think sometimes that thing might be a
hoax
and i don't i don't think i'd even fool
with it because
i don't know one soul that has this
and i know a lot of people that
represents just one of the logistical
conundrums for president-elect joe biden
he has set a goal of inoculating 100
million americans within a hundred days
of his inauguration on january 20th
john hendren al jazeera washington